Do you think psychedelics that I just mentioned earlier,
have a possibility of going to these
kind of same kind of places of
exploring ideas that are outside of our, um,
more commonplace understanding of the world?
Um, in my, yeah, I think so. Absolutely. However,
I think we have to be really careful about those because young people or people
in general, I should say absolutely can get hurt by them. I mean,
but we get hurt by alcohol. You know,
we drive our cars and we get kill each other. Um,
but psychedelics are really interesting because I know that within the history
of, of our country, um,
we have used psychedelics in various capacities for our military in
order to try to stimulate ideas and access places and
information that can't be accessed. Normally this is all fact.
Yeah. I talked to Matt for like four hours.
So we ran out of time being able to talk well,
I wanted to talk to him about MK ultra and, um, Ted Kaczynski.
There's so many mysterious things there.
There's like layers of what's known and what's not known as fascinating,
but I think what is interesting is, uh,
psychedelics were used the word attempted to be used as tools of different
kinds. That's the point.
So like we think of technology as tools, uh,
to enable us to do things and that same way that psychedelics
like many drugs could be used as tool, some more effective than others.
I don't think what you, I'm not sure what you can do effectively, um,
with alcohol. Uh, although somebody,
I think somebody commented somewhere on social media that, uh,
I don't know why everyone gives is so negative about alcohol
because, um, I think the person said that, um,
it's given me some of the most incredible, it enabled me,
uh,
to let go and have some of the most incredible experiences with friends in my
life. And it's true. We kind of sometimes say alcohol is dangerous.
It can make you do hope.
But the reality is it's also a fascinating
tool for letting go of trying to be somebody
maybe that you're not in allowing you to be yourself fully in whatever crazy
form that is and allow you to have really deep and interesting experiences with
those you love. So, uh, yeah,
even alcohol can be used as an effective tool for exploring experiences and
becoming, uh, expanding your mind and becoming a better person. So,
um, what the hell was I talking about? Uh, so yeah, so it's like,
so psychedelics and Oh, yeah. And, um, and, um, uh, MK ultra,
is there something interesting to say in the, and are historical.
Use of psychedelics?
I mean, think about it. When did we start doing that?
When did we start using them?
That's true. It's quite a long time ago. Right.
But okay. But true. But when did our government start experimenting with them?
With us? Okay. All government is the United States government. Yeah. Okay.
So that happened in around the 1950s. Okay.
After quote unquote, the 1940s where we have 47 and we have,
you know, this, you know, this Roswell type stuff going on. Okay.
Like crash sites and things like that. So I think that, um,
I think there might be a correlation there. I don't know what it is. Okay.
That's fascinating actually. Yeah. There's a lot of interesting things started.
Around that timeframe. Yeah.
And so eldest Huxley would say we opened the doors of perception. Okay.
And what flew in?
Um, man, that's beautifully put.